[Applause]
it's only happened once at paya data
like two years ago it was much more
terrifying than for some reason so help
here
so uh thank you all for being here thank
you for letting me speak today I'm my
name's Stephanie Kim I'm gonna talk
about investigating user experience with
a natural language analysis
so this talk focuses on the methodology
and intent of stating feedback form and
other user messaging data with our tools
and libraries for natural language
processing and machine learning so I'll
discuss potential trouble areas of
starting such a project from scratch
from a developer's perspective so
shocker I'm a developer but I also do
some data science work and it's usually
on doing natural language processing so
I love to help people build better
products by learning what users are
thinking and trying to understand how
they're feeling using machine learning
and text analysis so in 2012 I believe
it was I founded the Seattle PI ladies
location and currently I'm a developer
advocate and software engineer at
algorithmic and I also spend a lot of my
time increasing my own knowledge and
educating others on racial bias and AI
so shameless plug if you're I'm gonna be
around for a Riley AI I think it's like
next week I'm gonna be back or ods the
East and Boston come check out my racial
bias talk it's really important subject
so I'd love to see any of you there so
just a quick blurb about the guys who
pay the bills so algorithm you know we
believe that every application will
eventually become an intelligent
application but as my boss and CTO kenny
daniel said tensorflow is open source
scaling it's not so on our platform data
scientists and enterprise customers can
productionize their models and minutes
and turn them into scalable REST API
endpoints and they can privatize open
source or even monetize their models for
other developers to call on our open
marketplace so at the end of the talk
they'll be a promo code if you wanna try
us out I'll give you some free credits
so now let's get to the good stuff so
again this talk will cover the benefits
of investigating your user data we'll
talk about the types of helpful
techniques that are commonly used in
this kind of
else's and I'll talk about you know what
did you when the model is not performing
very well and then what to do with the
insights that you that you gained so why
investigate user feedback you know we
read user messages that come in whether
you're using feedback from vendors such
as for CEO or user a messaging data
tender like intercom you know often we
read these messages when we have time
but we don't get to look at overall
trends so users have some really
important insights and suggestions for
making your product better so it's
really important to know what they're
talking about so the goal is to increase
your awareness of what users are
thinking and feeling from a high-level
view and as I said as I mentioned you
want to look at those trends but then
you want to get those messages to the
appropriate teams so you can help your
users be happier and more successful
using your product so by analyzing
feedback you can find hidden trends and
patterns doing sentiment or even topic
based time series analysis you can find
bugs and design issues that might have
been esteem QA by doing anomaly
detection you can even gain new
opportunities to run a be test based off
the user feedback prioritize user
messages based off of topic or sentiment
and then respond accordingly and then
you can also learn about as I said
feature requests or needs from the users
they're the ones using it the most
they're the ones that it might be
failing on so you can also do
segmentation and targeted messaging for
instance you can identify all the
unhappy customers or people who asked
for certain features and reach out to
them specifically if you have non
anonymous data so if you that's a lot of
stuff that you could do with user
messaging and feedback form data so
about that data user feedback form data
is notoriously dirty like discussing
leader II some more than others
intercom data is the force that I've
touched if you first see feedback form
data is actually not too bad so you're
gonna be looking at having to strip out
HTML tags grammatical errors now
things that you might want to take out
for a document classification that you
want might want to keep for sentiment
classification are things like swear
words and emoticon like text which you'd
want to transform into some kind of
token a sentiment classifier would pick
up so note that for these slides I
they're based on intercom data which we
use that algorithm iya and in the past
education group I have used foresee a
feedback form got it so you also want to
make sure you create your custom stop
word lists and I like to ignore super
short comments that contain less than
some threshold of tokens I usually pick
three tokens
once all the stop words are taken out so
I love this isn't insightful data for
information or evil purposes but it can
be insightful for sentiment scores
especially if you if you know like it
say you're running an a/b test and you
know exactly you know what form was it
was changed in a certain way then that
sentiment might be useful so make sure
you keep in your goals in mind when
you're cleaning your data so of course
you'd also want to use a stammer or a
lemma tiser and you'd want to increase
versity with our remove sparse words or
if you're in Python and you might use
count vectorizer to help develop more
meaningful clusters in your data and
decrease the chance of creating them all
that overfits to your data so and by the
way I didn't mention so I said I'm a
developer I actually do Python and are I
have been using are more and more lately
so don't tell the pilot is so let's
first address what y'all probably
already know about performance that when
performance is your top priority and
you're working with large data datasets
you want to use data table which skills
better than data frames so this is
because data frames make a deep copy and
that means that it copies the entire
data frame to another location memory
and so it clogs down your machine and
when you're working with really large
data set so that could be a long way of
doing nothing but staring at your laptop
process are just got fun so when
performance isn't your top priority
a lot of us actually don't work with big
data you might want to use deep liar
for its readability flexibility and that
a nice abstracted data layer when you
need to connect to different data
sources I really I'm a big fan of deep
layer syntax I use it a lot regardless
you should use data tables F read
function versus read CSV when consuming
static data files because read CSV is
super slow you've got a major win on
speed using afraid so if you're dealing
with you know data that I mean you're
dealing with larger data sets you'll
want to use F read because it processes
the it imports the data immediately as
characters whereas read CSV first tries
to convert the data into integers and
factors and all this other stuff and
you're waiting a little bit longer you
also might want to try this is not a
package I've tried yet but I'm really
curious about playing around with it
it's Microsoft our Open Library which is
Microsoft's re-release of revolution
analytics are open it's a company who
Microsoft acquired a while back so
Microsoft our open has a packet that
package allows for multi-threaded
capabilities that speed up comma matrix
operations by quite a bit by using all
cores through parallel processing now
you will have to depend on Intel's math
kernal library to take advantage of it
so it's another dependency you know to
think about and they also have I believe
paid libraries as well that are even
faster I again I haven't checked out any
of those but it's kind of on my to-do
list so now that we've covered what you
should think about as far as libraries
and your data before you get started
analyzing let's talk about the types of
analysis that might be helpful so you
know when you're thinking about
investigating user data you'll probably
start with some basic text mining
techniques in order to find patterns in
your data so you'll be doing some
unsupervised clustering such as k-means
or dendrograms
or use topic modeling with Lda and then
you'll likely want to move to sentiment
analysis document classification or even
time series
anomaly detection as as I go along we'll
cover what models you would use for
these different types of use cases and
the insights you can gain from them so
first you might want to find hidden
patent patterns or topics in your data
so you can use different unsupervised
techniques such as in this slide there's
a k-means clustering that's used but I
actually kind of preferred dendrograms
there's just a little bit harder to the
you know see on the screen you can do
word clouds named entity recognition and
more and so on the upper left there's a
cluster with the terms air image
colorize which I'll talk about later but
I want to point out that a lot of these
unsupervised techniques the ones that I
mentioned probably are gonna produce
similar results because many of them use
euclidean distance so they'll give you
similar clusters but different
visualizations so it's probably not
worth your time to create all of them
for one analysis so choose the one that
that's best fits your goal not that I've
you know spent time creating like every
visualization or anything no I wouldn't
do that for instance if you're
generating reports then maybe choose one
with a nice visualization like I said I
like tender grams that way you could see
the hierarchy of clustered words that
often appear together but say you're
prepping for document class okay cute
classification then you're gonna
probably want to skip this and just go
to LD a to get you know your top
documents about topics so again keep
those goals in mind so you don't waste
time going down a rabbit hole so if you
want to satisfy your own curiosity about
what users are thinking about the most
and give your place to start when
thinking about document classification
or other information retrieval tasks
such as creating the topic labels for
Lda you can use the term frequency chart
so you'll probably want to use diagrams
versus you know grams or trigrams but
test with your own data to see what
works the best for you I've done this
project I think three times at two
different companies and I've
consistently found by grams to work the
best for this type of data so this
background frequency is using tf-idf
don't think I need to describe what that
is but in case it's a statistic that
measures the relative importance of an
Engram to the whole document
so in our case the five top terms our
machine learning sentiment analysis deep
learning error message and API key again
that Aramis is just that by Graham keeps
popping up so but we want to do l da and
LD a requires bag-of-words
so you can see is the top Vibrams
changed a little bit so if you're doing
document classification but your user
messages aren't labeled with topics yet
yeah I love all these LD gate and
document classification search for the
document classification titurius always
assume you have label data but a lot of
times that's not true so you can use LD
a which is a topic modeler that
discovers topics and documents and
assigns probabilities to those terms
making up the document or making up the
topics so notice on our slide we have
terms that make up a topic and behind
the scenes they have probabilities
assigned to them that indicate how well
they fit into that grouping but note
that we don't have any labels for topics
yet so looking at topic three we could
possibly infer that's about people
asking questions or going and deploying
their model talbert's meanwhile topic 4
might be about problems using on how to
use the Python client pythons are
probably our most popular language on
the marketplace I would say our is
probably the most popular in the
enterprise side so going back to the
term frequency chart we might decide to
call a topic for error message or we
could be more specific and call it
Python error message so these results
came from the topic models package from
tidy text which uses good sap sampling
but note that there are a lot of other
Lda models available in are such as text
Tyvek and the mallet package and I think
I haven't tried the text to BEC package
but Mallett tends to give pretty good
results so LD is so easy to implement on
your data and you should definitely test
these all out to see what gives you the
best results but I want to make a note
that text avec is likely going to be the
most performant because it's based on
warp LD a which is memory fishin so
after you've done your LD a you need to
map your documents to their associated
so again we before we just had the
topics but um we need to create the
labels for those - this document had 60%
probability of belonging in this topic
it was probably Lda called it topic 4 or
something like that
which I decided to call client API
errors so node client option request
server response cores error would have
the label client API errors and that
label I made up based off of my domain
knowledge I then use these mappings to
create a training set for document
classification since I don't already
have a label data set so the end goal
here is that you know you have your
topics and they're mapped to documents
and now you can do some investigation
into the UI and find out areas that
users might be having trouble with so a
my previous job at Apollo education
group I found that people were having
trouble using a confusing drop-down and
so it wasn't actually a bug it was a a
UI issue so also um an algorithm yeah
after manually reading the documents
that mapped to the topics found in the
previous slide I revisited our Python
Docs client Docs and our modal model
hosting Docs and I decided to just make
them a little bit clearer for beginners
and do a little bit more hand-holding in
the in the documentation so and now that
you have these label documents again you
can train the model for document
classification speaking of which now
we'll go through some types of models
you might want to try for classification
tasks so whether you're training a
document or a sentiment classification
model most models accuracy and
performance depends upon how many
classes you're trying to classify on and
how large of a data is that you have
access to so more classes require more
data which is you know really important
when you're looking at document
classification you don't want to have
too many classes so here are some broad
guidelines but again you really have to
test your own data on various models to
see what will work best on your data set
so many people's go to naive Bayes
especially if you don't have a ton of
but if you have some more data and you
want a more robust mall you could try
random forests but note that choosing
random forest will give you most likely
a boost in accuracy but you'll lose
speed which is really important in rural
world applications if your production
production izing your model so usually a
naivebayes is good enough for the real
world
so for decent accuracy but kind of a
lack of scalability because of word
embeddings are a little slow you might
want to try word Tyvek via word vectors
package in our text avec which i already
mentioned which is similar to pythons
docked avec or even ld8 avec which
combines word Tyvek word embeddings with
lDA's topic modeling i am really curious
to use that one I haven't played around
with it yet but that's another on my
to-do list so when you don't have enough
data to train your model especially like
if you only have maybe a year's worth or
less of user messaging data don't
discard the many pre train sentiment
models out there or has some and you
know other there are other open source
sentiment pre train models out there so
feedback form data is fairly similar to
social data so it has a lot of
misspelled words fragmented sentences
emoticons Lang etc so it's useful to
check out pre train models if you don't
have enough data to train your own so
lastly if you have the infrastructure
available for GPUs and you have a lot of
data for each class and time is on your
side for training then you can use deep
learning I wouldn't suggest like that
being your starting point but you could
try convolutional neural nets for
classification tasks and that way you
won't have to focus on future
engineering and you should get pretty
good results but that's not always the
case so definitely not the place to
start out with so make sure you
understand your priorities are you
looking for performance or are you
looking for accuracy and based decisions
on your data size and the your available
infrastructure
all right so one of the most useful
analysis you can do on user data is just
discover how user sentiment changes over
time so you're looking at you know your
message data on a daily basis that's
really hard to see trends so but even
more insightful is when you integrate
release dates as benchmarks in order to
gauge sentiment changes so say you have
a major design release or maybe even in
a demo of one your API is released in
the wild and you want to find out how
users felt about it a little
foreshadowing there so notice the spike
in negative sentiment it has to do with
that cluster we found in the k-means
slide that you know by gram error
message but honestly I'm still too
traumatized to talk about it
sounded depending on the vendor I
already mentioned a couple of vendors
that people use for collecting user
message data you might be lucky to
enough to have the URI that the former
comment was made on and that way you can
aggregate sentiment by pages so for
example if you have if you want to find
the sentiment scores for a landing page
and you can run and you're running a be
tests on different styles you can gain
extra insight the beyond conversion
rates and pull out the negative comments
to see what issues users were having
with that style but I want to mention
again here that while we're looking at
the overall trends we're then drilling
down with a more narrowed scope to view
our highest priority areas and then
we're checking those messages manually
and responding accordingly because
machine learning and automation only
goes so far and understanding what users
are thinking and how they're feeling
so besides sentiment you could do a time
series analysis on topics so I'm finally
ready to talk about what happened in
mid-2000 mid-2017
to get such somber clusters in sentiment
so this slide shows a huge spike that
occurred for the bigram
error message and this was due to a demo
we created for colorizer algorithm that
developers could use in their apps to
colorize their black and white photos
via our API so the reason we're getting
so many user messages that contain the
bike
error message and such negative cements
and our user messaging was that the demo
landed on a few genealogy and
photography sites and non developers
were sending us messages that they were
having difficulties uploading their
black-and-white images to our demo they
thought this was like just software that
they could use to and it was it was just
a simple simple demo to show how easy it
was to you know call the colorizer
algorithm VR API so at the time we found
these messages manually but if you have
a live data stream and are building out
really cool real-time dashboards you
might want to track a few important
engrams that you can either get from the
frequency char that we looked at or the
topics from a topic modeler like Lda and
that way you can get a feel of what
users are talking about and set up
alerts to notify if it's over under a
certain threshold for anomaly detection
so you could see even with this
completely unexpected example it's
really helpful to track what users are
talking about in real time so that you
can help them use your app your API or
in this case where you direct them to an
iOS app to colorize their black and
white photos when they aren't your
target user so if you want to do time
series to understand overall trends in
your data and even forecast future
trends and topics or sentiment you might
want to try some of the models shown on
the slide I'm not going to go into
details but a quick cap Auto regressive
integrated moving average is kind of my
go-to and it's the one I know best so I
usually do that for some quick
forecasting and then on the slide for
sentiment analysis I believed I use Holt
winters which is a triple exponential
smoothing model so I couple weeks ago
actually I was I was doing some Google
searches on stuff and I came across
profit which there was an awesome talk
about yesterday so I did a really quick
proof of concept it's super easy to get
up and running with that unfortunately
it kept crashing our when I tried to
plot it so I've got some debugging work
to do to figure
out but it's a super user-friendly
really fast to get up and running so I
suggest checking that out
if you're looking to detect anomalies
such as our colorizer spike you could
use a support vector machine algorithm
or k nearest neighbor twitter has also
put out a promising anomaly detection
model that's available for our called
anomaly detection i haven't played
around with that one yet but I've heard
good things so definitely another one to
check out so and of course I have to
talk about one of our algorithm
developers just put out a generative
forecasting model called generative
forecast an anomaly detection model
called threshold anomaly detection I
haven't checked out either I'm gonna be
honest about that but he's a pretty
talented guy so you might want to look
at those too so and of course if you
have a ton of data and you again you
have the infrastructure to train your
model you might want to look at a RNN
variant long short-term memory model
which has really good results for
anomaly detection and other
classification problems and that's due
to Ellis team's ability to recall older
information from previous passes in the
network that other neural nets don't
include so with time series anomaly
detection you can detect and then
prioritize your groups of users that
have problems using your product or site
and then respond to them quickly and
triage the issue to their appropriate
team lead so sometimes your model is not
performing how am i doing on time Oh way
over I'm so sorry
ok so ok we're done and that's ok I'll
post these slides up somewhere so here
you could take a picture of the promo
code if you want to check this out thank
you so much for having me
[Applause]
you